today I would like to make an appeal to
the European sinkers to men and women of
culture to join the debate on the future
of Europe we need them I think far too
much of the conversation that we are
having is with citizens as consumers in
purely economic language as economic
units rather than citizenry in one way
Europe has fulfilled its original dream
we are living in peace and we are
trading only that trading isn't enough
peace is a stationary state once you
have peace you cannot have more of it
but you can always have more trade and
more growth we need to continue to tell
the story of Europe like a book you
cannot only stay in the first pages even
if the first pages were extremely
beautiful mind checking on you possibly
i'm sorry over PSV on co-ed no co party
not a partnership moo-hyun la silla
dynasty episode of 16 not change to grab
a clean online bargain a full auto key
challenges are erupted the only thing we
need to be radical about is not giving
in to any form of radicalism that
requires courage the only thing that can
make Europe a success is what lives in
the hearts and the minds of the citizens
one of my works which was called stories
one and you have a 12 different good
news bad news scenarios and this is like
one of the things which was written
there you have this tiny little robe
which says a story a good end of a story
and a better model story and this is my
own personal narrative as long as I have
in my hands that little rope and I do
know that I have the bad and the good
end in my hands I can keep writing we
need to create that emotional link
between the citizens of Europe and our
Europe
no dobbiamo kappa runic hace muchos
impression k me pros mediation la ropa
por decir ese SI ancora influent a texas
even el mundo ochre assessor Ephraim men
tata aig influent despite national
differences we hear similar demands in
the streets of many european countries
active citizenship is one of the
positive collateral results of the
present developments bebado it Imogen RV
noon desert o coastal desert o de la non
como sensei you resent in questo desire
Tony giorno e questo cierto el libro eq
co cheapo entrare a pot o que habia una
de a Demeter a disposizione a la
competizione inna ropa de vesser trolley
day a non trolley persona I think the
people who actually enjoy europe now
should speak up the Erasmus generation
is time for them to speak up is not
enough to spend time across Europe to
intermarry and to travel as I do Europe
is a Europe
oh by inter consistently to leave
islamic push typed in a farm through its
on demand or not dogged the operation on
Ewing to tear down walls and build
bridges wrought world is our European
story for years to come as artists
intellectuals and scientists and first
and foremost our citizens it is our
responsibility to join the debate on the
future of Europe Rene sauce and
cosmopolitanism RV to cultural ideals we
look to and considered vital as part of
the Europe of today and the Europe of
tomorrow